salut romance qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu
veux avec ton badge vérifie parce que
j'ai l'impression et des boutons sur la
prononce pas ce mot là encore ce furent
démonétisé face à la recrudescence de
démonétisation et dans le souci est de
pouvoir continuer à vous proposer des
contenus pédagogiques sur le thème de la
textualité ce vidéogrammes fort
astucieusement usage de barrow nîmes 1
paronymes c'est un mot qui ressemble
beaucoup à un autre par exemple
textualité c'est un patronyme de abane
merde je peux pas le dire
d'ailleurs pour surveiller l'efficacité
de cette méthode aussi bien sur les
termes que sur les images d'illustration
votre lecteur vidéo graphique a été
équipée d'un démon à 10 mètres juste là
en bas comme romain vous avez peut-être
déjà transpiré un bon coup en découvrant
un truc bizarre sur vos organes géniaux
et comme cet effet on n'est pas du genre
à vous laisser tomber je vous propose de
faire un petit point sur les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles
alors déjà c'est quoi la différence
entre une maladie sexuellement
transmissible et une infection
sexuellement transmissible et ben en
fait il y en a pas vraiment dans la
mesure où ça des villes les mêmes cas de
figure c'est à dire des trucs pas cool
qu'on attrape à l'occasion d'un rapport
textuel tôt sauf que quand on dit
infections on parle de contamination
alors que quand on parle de maladie
ça y est c'est fait s'est installée
voilà un petit peu de l'étape d'après et
comme l'idée c'est de prévenir pour pas
avoir à guérir on préfère parler d'
infections sexuellement transmissibles
et donc oui c'est des infections parce
qu'on parle de sales bêtes qu'on se
transmet par voie textuel quand on
pratique le texte ça peut être des
bactéries comme dans le cas de la
gonorrhée déclame idiot de la syphilis
ou du chantre vous des parasites comme
sont là trichomonase ou un virus comme
avec le vih l'hépatite b l'herpès
nickelés kg oki appelé crédoc
la maladie se passe alors en ont parlé
qu'en maintenant voilà alors il y en a
d'autres mais ça assez vilain principal
est alors temps que j'y suis vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler des blue
apple une infection sexuellement
transmissible qui faire ressembler vos
organes géniaux à une gaufre bleus d'où
le nom eh ben c'est une légende urbaine
ça n'existe bon mais alors qu'est ce qui
doit vous alarmer c'est quoi les signes
qui doit vous inciter à prendre les
choses en main
[Musique]
[Rires]
globalement ça reste assez localiser ça
peut être des lésions au niveau de la
bulle ou du phénix comme par exemple des
boutons des espèces de petites verrues
ou des ulcérations c'est à dire des
sortes de petits trous un petit peu
comme des petites plaies ça peut
s'accompagner de démangeaisons et
parfois d'écoulement par la berge ou par
le vacherin voire de brûlures quand vous
buriné là c'est chiant ça prête à
confusion parce que buriné ça peut
vouloir dire que bon ça peut aussi
brûler quand vous buriné cancan victis
et quand on fait cuire dans tous ces cas
de figure vous appelez votre médecin
pour qu'il vous prescrive un traitement
parce que la plupart du temps ça guérit
pas tout seul mais ça soigne et quand
vous avez raccroché vous passer un petit
coup de fil à votre ou à vos partenaires
pour qu'ils prennent rendez vous aussi
mais attention attention attention
attention
si en attendant le mieux c'est de ne pas
en arriver là
le mieux c'est de ne pas avoir à guérir
le mieux c'est de prévenir
bravo roman la prévention c'est
important le mieux c'est de tout faire
pour ne pas attraper d'infections
sexuellement transmissibles
parce qu'une fois que les signes sont là
bas c'est trop tard et pire parfois il
n'y a pas de signes ou alors il arrive
très tard ou alors ils sont pas très
spécifique c'est-à-dire qu'ils peuvent
ressembler à plein d'autres trucs
c'est le cas du vih ou l'hépatite b par
exemple le problème c'est qu'en
attendant non seulement on soigne pas
mais en plus on risque de contaminer
d'autres personnes donc deux règles d'or
on se protège et on se dépistent alors
pour se protéger la base c'est la
compote sylla la conquête anglaise
réserve est masculin ou féminin c'est la
protection la plus efficace on peut même
dire que c'est la seule protection
efficace
petite précision quand même la compote
ça protège du principal mode de
contamination c'est à dire le contact
entre les muqueuses génial les bus que
c'est une petite peau très fine qui
tapissent certains organes comme ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui
mais dans certains cas comme les
papillomavirus qui cause notamment les
condylomes ou avec l'herpès par exemple
la contamination peut aussi se faire par
contact avec la bouche ou les mains
alors pour les rapports bucco-génitaux
d'abord il faut savoir que si on a des
petites plaies dans la bouche ça
augmente le risque de contamination
donc soyez attentifs à ça et ne vous
brossez palais dans moins d'une heure
avant ça risque d'irriter les gencives
ensuite il ya les protections pour
pratiquer une délation vous pouvez
utiliser des compotes sans lubrifiant
voir aromatisées et pour le cumulonimbus
ou pour les relents gus il ya la digue
dentaire
je vous laisse chercher ça sur google ou
dans ma vidéo sur le sida que je vous
remets en garde un faux bond après pour
les mains j'avoue
très fort sur mutuellement un maximum de
plaisir sensuel dernière chose
concernant les protections
si on change de zone d'exploration en
cours de route on change de compote
pareil si on change de partenaire sinon
celui qui porte la compote
il reste protégé mais pas les autres
donc vous avez des solutions pour
diminuer le plus possible le risque de
contamination
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas d'où
l'intérêt du dépistage
si on décide de se passer de protection
parce qu'on se pose avec un ou une
partenaire par exemple la première chose
à faire c'est que les deux se fassent
dépister pour ça vous pouvez aller voir
votre médecin ou alors il ya des centres
de dépistages gratuits un peu partout je
vous mets un lien dans la description
pour trouver le plus proche de chez vous
ensuite deux choses en cas de pratiques
à risque avec un autre partenaire
ça peut arriver bon il va vous vous
dépister à nouveau et vous remettez des
protections et puis bien sûr quand vous
arrêtez les compotes il faut penser à un
autre mode de contraception
si c'était le seul que nous utilisions
côté c'est bien ce que je pensais vous
avez attrapé une infection sexuellement
transmissible
oh mon dieu mais qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un garçon donc on récapitule on se
protège onze des pistes on va voir le
médecin si on a des signes ou si on a un
doute et si on a une infection
sexuellement transmissible
on se protège à nouveau si on avait
arrêté de le faire et on prévient son ou
ses partenaires précédent alors sur ce
dernier point je suis d'accord ça peut
être inconfortable comme situation mais
d'abord c'est hyper important pour eux
ou pour l impasse que plus on se fait
soigner tôt mieux c'est - on risque de
complications mais pour se faire soigner
l'info est au courant le problème c'est
que dans ces cas là le réflexe est
souvent vouloir trouver un responsable
et qui m'a refilé ça ce truc de vouloir
absolument trouver un responsable c'est
valable pour plein d'autres situations
c'est humain mais c'est pas pour autant
que c'est bien et en plus en
l'occurrence non seulement ça sert à
rien et ça risque de dissuader les gens
de prévenir les autres mais surtout la
majorité du temps c'est impossible de
savoir d'abord parce que pour une même
infection
le temps d'incubation c'est à dire le
temps entre le moment de la
contamination et les premiers signes il
peut aller de quelques jours ou quelques
semaines à plusieurs années donc c'est
pas forcément votre partenaire actuel ni
même le précédent où la précédente qui
vous l'a refilé est aussi oublié pas un
truc si un ancien partenaire vous rappel
pour vous dire qu'on lui a trouvé
quelque chose m'a dit vous que ok vous
voulez peut-être filet mais si ça trouve
c'est vous qui lui avait refilé et dans
tous les cas on s'en fout ça change rien
faites vous dépister utiliser des
protections en attendant les résultats
et fait vous soigner après si besoin
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui
si vous avez des questions si vous avez
des doutes sur votre cas personnel il ya
plusieurs plateformes en ligne ou par
téléphone que vous pouvez contacter je
vous mets tous les liens dans la
description on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]